És
mikor tudtam, hogy az első kezelés után
el fog hullni a hajam, akkor úgy is
voltunk egyezve, hogy ketten fogunk
elmenni és levágatom a hajam. De hála a
drága jó Istennek, hogy nem sikerült ez
így, merthogy jött egy olyan gondolat
egyik délelőtt, hogy éreztem, hogy meg
van halva a hajam.
Az különben az egy nagyon
érdekes, erős érzés, és hogy ez nem
fogja kibírni, hogy megvárjam a fiamat,
és hogy inkább azelőtt én elmegyek és
levágatom. És nagyon jó volt, hogy nem
volt ott, mert egy óriási óriási erős
gyász volt akkor bennem. Tehát amíg
levágták a hajamat, akkor tudatosult
bennem, hogy igenis most ez egy ez egy
ez egy kemény dolog, amit csinálok.
Úgyhogy, hogy teljesen, tehát úgy
éreztem, hogy minden
szépségemtől
megfosztottak, teljesen
lecsupaszítottak, és hogy ezt így kell
csinálni.
[Zene]